They will suck the blood out of you and throw you away when they're finished.
Perhaps you'd better not put that on the tape right?
How did you start Aikido?
When I started, I didn't have any idea of what Aikido was supposed to be.
It was a martial art of some sort, it was Aikido.
You go on the mat and you're thrown and so on... it was interesting.
I didn't practice it for a particular reason, it was something interesting to do.
I got to know the teacher.
He told me about this strange martial art based on love.
I was studying philosophy at the University of Sussex and I thought "this is not possible",
so I dismissed it.
He was a 3rd Dan, he had been captain of the club in the University of Tokyo.
He invited me onto the mat and I think he used shihonage,
I remember going down immediately and thinking "oh, very interesting".
His English wasn't very good I think, so he showed.
It's a way of teaching that I've become more accustomed to over the years.
He showed without much physical or verbal explanation.
It was very attractive.
The idea was that you had a kind of physico-physcial relationship with the person you were training with
and if he attacked, you were supposed to emerge in an advantageous situation.
If you were the attacker, the situation was reversed so it was really quite fair.
There was no competition at all.
Of course, we weren't particularly fit even though at the time, I was doing long distance cross country running
so I had plenty of stamina but there were some muscles that didn't really get exercised.
I found out afterwards that he was attached to a dojo,
which I think would normally be thought of as rather right wing in Japan, politically...
GE: Aren't they all?
Well they are, but that one especially so, it was right wing, proudly displaying it, in the Shiseikan Dojo.
So, at the time that he practiced with us,
he was concerned to portray the Emperor and the Emperor system in a way that he thought had to be understood by non-japanese.
and we didn't either really understand it, or we what we understood, we didn't agree with.
because we had also read our history of WWII and made our own conclusions,
aided by parents and friends who actually fought in the war.
I still know him, we are friends, we still correspond from time to time, though he's got older now.
He went back to Japan and I used to go in the dojo of Chiba Sensei in London.
Chiba Kazuo Sensei was quite different, the way he taught, the way he practiced, and the way he handled himself.
I think he felt himself as the closest thing to a traditional Japanese Samurai.
The way he interacted with his students, to my mind, was problematic.
His own students wouldn't agree at all, he was a fantastic teacher.
And OK.
And then I tried the resolve the contradictions... well, the clash of temperament between those two.
I understand that you also studied in America for a while...
My subject area was philosophy
and I had decided to begin at the beginning
and I was studying ancient Greek philosophy, pre-Socratics, Plato, Aristotle, stoics.
But to do that properly you need Greek
and so Sussex didn't offer Greek so I went to America.
I got a scholarship at Harvard University in the classics department.
Well, my initial Japanese friend who was a teacher approached the Aikikai and gave me the name of a teacher.
named Kanai Mitsunari Sensei, who was Chiba Sensei's school friend.
And again he was quite different as well.
He wasn't trying to be a Samurai in any sense of the word.
I was practicing, he liked it, he'd been sent to teach in America, which he did,
he didn't like the politics and simply got on with practicing
He also did Iaido with a few of his Japanese yudansha.
So i had 2 years there, why, because Harvard was a very political university
and my supervisor went back to England
so I decided to follow him back and went to the University of London,
and the teacher there was a man named Minoru Kanetsuka.
I was at University College London and there was a dojo at the college so I was able to resume my Harvard-type existence.
and trained and did my PhD at well.
That provided a good balance.
I got my Shodan in London from Kanetsuka Sensei.
I then became a kind of junior instructor in the main dojo in London.
We had to keep a diary of what we taught
It was a very conservative setup.
We always began with a big warm-up and then shomenuchi suwariwaza ikkyo.
then hanmi handachi
and only then we'd other taijutsu techniques.
In the second part of the class we'd do weapons.
Kanetsuka had a makiwara, you've seen it outside in the garden, and we would do uchikomi, uchikomi, uchikomi, taimenuchi...
At the time, he was attracted to the style of Saito Sensei,
because the books had come out at that time and he was studying them.
Only later did I find out that there were political issues, there was Iwama, and there was Tokyo.
Did these teachers all influence your views about Aikido?
The experience of training in America was different from the experience of training in England,
which was different again form the experience of training with Taho-san the first time.
Then going back to England again and seeing Kanetsuka Sensei, who was Chiba Sensei's successor if you like,
and the problems he had with Chiba's own students who were senior.
His Aikido was very nice, very good
but I kept thinking well, what's an Aikido Sensei supposed to be, what's he supposed to do
what were the job descriptions appart from learning the techniques and teaching them?
You know, what you're supposed to be,
especially now that some of the more traditional Shihan complain that it's too much of a busyness.
In soem sense their idea is that it must be some kind of a vocation
All of my teachers, in fact, with no exception, have been Japanese.
One question is, "Is your focus of Aikido on the technique or on the teacher?"
You practice Aikido to learn techniques or whatever
waza, I think is a better word, I don't like the word technqiue really
In my own case, finding a teacher was really secondary.
because it depended initially on where I was,
then I would look for a dojo and go learn from the teacher in the dojo
Other people didn't do this, other people found a teacher and kept with that teacher for most of their Aikido lives.
Some people would say that unless you find a teacher that you like and you fit, you can't really start.
I don't really agree.
I think that the way you go to a dojo and learn about the art,
the way the art fits you and the way you fit the art is defferent from person to person.
I found it useful to learn basics from three different teachers, because it was good learning experience.
but I never focused especially on one.
This is another thing about Aikido, you don't stop training and you don't stop learning something.
As I got older I had to rebuild the way I practice,
because I'm no longer a 20-year-old, or a 30, or a 40-year-old,
so you have to do this.
To my mind, it's the principles defining the art that are the most important, and not the teacher who manifests the art at any one time.
Different teachers have different ways of doing it, and that's OK, not a problem, but my focus is not.
In a way, it's chiken and egg I suppose because
You go to the dojo and you learn what you can learn form the teacher in the dojo, and other people,
and that adds to the stock, if you like, of your Aikido knowledge, however you want to call it.
With Chiba Sensei, I did find people who believed that Chiba Sensei was a fantastic teacher, as he was,
but he was the only one, other teachers weren't really a factor, and I didn't share that view.
What brought you to Japan?
When I was at Harvard, I had plans of going to Japan.
The reason for this is that I bought a book called Aikido written by Kisshomaru Ueshiba.
I think you know the book, in English, with photographs of a young Chiba and a young Tamura taking ukemi.
In the book, there was an explanation of the founder and Aikido, ans so on.
Training in Japan seemed attractive.
I had been told by Chiba Shihan: "Do not go to Japan just to practice Aikido"
He said: "Go to Japan with another means of support, another reason for existing than Aikido".
That was his advice and I followed it.
It meant finding a university because I thought it was very difficult to go and work for a company, and I'm an academic.
So I did this and eventually I was offered positions, and the one that I chose was at Hiroshima University, so I came here.
This house had been lived in by a professor.
I have an arrangement such that I don't own it but I partly own it, I rebuild it when it needs rebuilding.
The neighbourhood is a traditional Japanese neighbourhood
and all the neighbors have been here also for many years, so I'm known as the foreign teacher.
I'm Sensei basically in the neighborhood, everybody knows who I am.
I became embedded if you like.
To do this, you need Japanese, there is no question.
Hiroshima is not like Tokyo where you can get away with very little Japanese, you need Japanese.
There is a very strong dialect also and I had no idea what my Aikido teachers were saying to me for the first few years.
Did you train at the Tokyo Hombu Dojo at that time?
When I came, a colleague took me to Tokyo and I went to the Hombu.
I had met Kisshomaru Ueshiba in America before.
Very interesting...
What I mean is in America I was practicing hard right.
Kisshomaru's way was very smooth and very circular, he was very frail in many ways,
and clearly, he knew what he was doing.
I hadn't talked to him so when I met Kisshomaru in Hombu, I went to the house next door to the dojo,
I was invited in and I was with Fujita Shihan.
I found out later that Fujita Shihan had actually started the dojo in Hiroshima when he was a student at Takushoku University.
So he went back a long way with the teacher here whose name was Kitahira Sensei.
So I met Fujita Sensei and we had a little tour of the Hombu and then we went to the house and I met Kisshomaru.
We sat down and had some tea, his wife brought tea and okashi (snacks)
We had a talk, he was very happy that I came to Japan and was in Hiroshima,
Unfortunately it was a bit far away from Tokyo but he hoped that I would come to the Hombu as often as possible and practice.
My colleague was translating.
When we'd finish the interview ad we were walking the narrow street form the Hombu to the mai road,
I asked him and he said: well, I've got mixed feelings about this actually"
"Yeah it's Aikido, the martial arts have a very negative sort of chachet in Japan"
"so if a daughter of mine wanted to marry a Hombu Dojo Shihan I would have big problems".
And I thought "oh, very interesting..."
How was you practice in Hiroshima?
One thing I did is to stop teaching Aikido.
I went to the dojo.
Fujita Sensei had told the teacher here,
and I began to go to the dojo, I became a member.
I became independent, for want of a better word, in around 2003 or 2004.
So 25 years or so, I trained in that dojo, probably.
All the time.
So that's long period of time under one teacher I think.
When I first came I can remember: "Oh, they're doing it quite differently".
It was rather old-fashioned.
I saw Kitihira Sensei do stuff that I had never seen before.
That was getting very interesting, it was very sharp, straight Aikido, lots of atemi.
One thing that was interesting is that three Shihan would come from the Hombu every year.
There was normally Friday, Saturday, and Sunday training sessions.
The spring seminar would be run by Tada Sensei,
the autumn seminar, by Yamaguchi Sensei,
and then in-between, there'd be a seminar with Fujita Sensei
but he would sometimes give up his place to another Shihan
and so Rinjiro Shirata came down here once and later, Saito Sensei as well.
I knew him from before so I was able to partner him for sword work on the Sunday.
That was a very good kind of background.
Kitihira Sensei is now 8th Dan I think.
For example once, he stopped everybody and said: "OK, now let's do iriminage"
and for 2 hours, we practiced iriminage.
He invited all the senior Yudansha to come on and show what you did.
We all said: "Oh, look at the feet, and the hands, and the head, it's very interesting, its iriminage but it's all different".
I was also invited and I went up.
We were doing it the way you cut down, make a circle, and then throw, just like Kisshomaru used to do it.
The way I moved he said: "You're moving the same way as we are".
I think my feet... I was somehow going forward rather than going backwards.
Now, I was amazed because Kitihira Sensie had no problem with actually asking everybody to show
and then stealing, borrowing, using what he saw, and that to my mind was a very good way.
Kitihira Sensei was unusual in the sense that he didn't expect us to imitate his waza.
It was very difficult to do sometimes and he was quite old, his ukemi was not very good because he wasn't young
but he was quite strong and he was also learning.
I haven't met him for a good while but he used to practice and research all the time.
So to my mind, that was a good dojo to go to.
So that was a little bit like at Hombu?
I don't know, the Hombu is the Hombu, and I've heard conflicting stories about training there.
In the Hombu, there are a large number of teachers.
I suppose you're meant to go to all the classes but I suppose eventually you tend to favor one or two teachers over the others.
Arikawa Sensei told me very proudly that there were very few students in his classes.
I didn't ask him why because it was pretty obvious why, after seeing him on the mat!
Anyway, he didn't mind this, but here, Kitihira Sensei always taught.
Did you take on responsibilities during these 25 years at the Dojo?
Eventually, I would sit with him when the Dan examinations were held
because I would always ask people to do things that they hadn't prepared for.
He found that entertaining in many ways because there was always a panic,
I would ask for something, especially the students, and they hadn't practiced it
and they would go: "oh he is asking this..." so there were little groups
behind the main line up, frantically practicing so that when their turn came they would know.
And of course I could see it so I always asked something different that they hadn't prepared for.
So if doing techniques in different ways was accepted in the dojo, how about cross-training in different places?
Kitihira Sensei did not like students going to other dojos, he made that very clear.
I happened to be teaching in another university titled Hiroshima Shurei Univeristy,
I was a part-time teacher and there was an Aikido club.
Now i wouldn't do this but initially I went and I asked somebody, a colleague, about Aikido and Shudo and they said: "oh we'll go and practice".
So I went and met the instructor, who was a student of Nishio Sensei
Then I met all these other people who came form the main dojo and said: "Peter, don't tell anybody that I practice here, keep it secret".
I though: "How very interesting, yes well..." and I did of course.
It was Nishio Aikido.
But I couldn't train. If it were found that that I was training there, there would have been a terrible explosion.
Nishio Sensei was a very interesting person, quite different.
I can remember once with a certain Hombu Shihan, being told in great details why Nishio Sensei both was and was not a Hombu Shihan.
The intellectual gymnastics were really quite interesting.
One of the reasons why I got to know him quite well was that as I told you, there was a dojo in Saijo, Higashi Hiroshima.
That was started by two colleagues of mine.
A lady named Carolin Funck, I met here first.
I met her first, she had come to Hiroshima University and she was in the same faculty as I was
They were there with her husband Werner Steinhaus
Now, they said Peter, we need to open a dojo, why don't you open a dojo?
And I said: "well, you know..." I was actually quite happy training in Kenshibu as it was, the main dojo.
But I encountered problems because the two Germans had a very clear idea of what they wanted to do.
I was regarded as the senior of the 3 and Kitihira Sensei and I sort of gradually fell apart in this respect.
That cause me to think about issues like "well I'm doing my Aikido, and not his or theirs" so those were questions I hadn't really thought about before.
But I agreed to start a dojo, we eventually worked out a common framework so that when we opened the dojo,
there'd be no major conflict in how we actually taught the classes because the dojo was going to be run be the three of us, not by one.
So that's how it's worked.
I think we're in our 12th year now.
So now, the membership is about 50 and of those there is about 20 there at any one time.
Well in one sense it's a typical local dojo, there are no non-Japanese students except for one man who is Korean, and I think there is a Chinese as well,
but the teachers are all foreign and I don't think I know any other dojo that's quite like this.
where really, I'm the chief instructor, but Carolyn and Werner instruct together.
So it's really a dojo where the teaching is shared.
So the students also learn to see 3 different ways of doing it.
Because I've train for so long that it just sort of comes out.
I just do what I do and sometimes, I forget the rules that we agreed
Sometimes I don't do ikkyo quite correctly in the way that they've established but they know, the students.
We now have, oh I think that the senior students are now 3rd Dan.
So it has followed the typical trajectory.
and the only difference is that the dojo is a general dojo for Japanese people and all the teachers are foreign.
To my mind, it's a very good situation.
How it will continue, I don't know.
I have no plan to go back to England but I can't see myself training when I'm a hundred if I ever live that long.
So it might well be that the students will take over and that's fine, we have enough students who want to do this.
Are you affiliated to your old dojo?
When we built the dojo, initally, the prefecture association approached us and said:
"Hadn't you better be independent? Because your dojo is in a very unusual situation"
I asked the Hombu and Doshu said "no, keep it a member of Kenshibu for a moment, join the normal, the local organizaton"
And we did but, stresses and strains, we somehow changed,
So to my mind, it would have been better to be independent from the beginning, and eventually it happened.
It happened, really because I was very noisy in informing Hombu about what was going on.
Eventually, they said "Go your own way" and I received permission to hold Dan grades examinations and great, that's how it followed.
Now that set a precedent and it's more generally accepted that if a Hombu Shihan comes and does a seminar,
then they will invite you from the other dojos which are not directly in that group.
Are you involved with other dojos?
When I stared practicing in Japan, in Hiroshima, I practiced with the other dojo members
and I got to know a few people.
One of them, whom you'll meet, I've practiced with him for years.
His name is Motooka and when I became independent, he wanted to be independent too.
He has the idea of keeping the old type of Aikido alive somehow,
much more traditional, the way it was taught 40 or 50 years ago.
He thinks that's changed, and I don't think I can deny this, that it has changed in some respects.
Anyway, he wanted to know how to do it and wether he could follow the same pattern as I did
so I took him to the Hombu once and introduced him to Doshu and we talked.
I think we met Osawa Sensei who was in charge of the Japanese Dan structure and what not.
He said: "You can't give your own Dan ranks yet but what you should do is ask somebody who can.
So I was asked if I would go to the dojo to be the chief instructor,
and I was a bit... I said yes but, it was a bit difficult because he was actually senior to me in terms of Dan rank
and here was I going into his dojo.
He has his own way of practicing, as I had mine, and so it then occurred that the best thing to do is weapons.
Motooka-san was eventually given permission to give his own grades, to recommend promotions.
The arrangements are that he does the Kyu grades and I do the Dan grades.
What weapons system do you teach?
I had picked up from training with Chiba Sensei, especially going to summer schools in America,
I'd learn the 31 jo kata and I'd learned the paired kata, ad also the 13 awase, kumitachi, and so on.
Kitihira Sensei had some serious rank in jojutsu and had learned weapons yes, no question,
but he didn't practice weapons very much.
I think he believed what he was told by Fujita Sensei that by the end of his life, O Sensei didn't actually use weapons, now I've no idea whether that's true or not.
So he didn't teach weapons very much.
Now I had been brought up, from the very beginning,
the man who came form Tokyo University did weapons as well,
and I discovered in Europe, that every Japanese Shihan had hsi own weapons system
and so to my mind, that's very strange, that they don't do weapons in the Hombu but everybody does outside, and of course in Iwama.
So we started teaching weapons and I started teaching the kids the 31 kata.
So if you go to the dojo this evening early enough, you find them in English, "1, 2, 3, 4..." as they go from 1 to 31.
So it has worked.
His dojo is Futabanosato, the main dojo so we have a relationship with our dojo so that our students are members of both.